[Musique]
allez les filles venez dire bonjour à
votre grand-mère
seulement pour quelques jours essayez de
pas mettre le feu à la maison OK
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ici les enfants
pour s'amuser moi ce que je préférais
c'était qu'on me raconte des histoires
avant de m'endormir tu peux me raconter
une des sorcières les plus cruelles
buvez le sang des enfants pour leur
voler leur jeunesse les sorcières
et elles vont venir te trouver
je suis végétarienne il y a pas autre
chose on n'est pas au restaurant Ma
petite mère tu dois bien manger si tu
veux aller mieux
tu crois que ma grand-mère pourrait être
une
sorcière madame Josepha est une femme
très dure mais en réalité c'est un amour
elle ne ferait pas de mal à une mouche
les histoires d'abigaëlle ton rendu
folle
et si papa et maman est revenu pas nous
chercher
grand-mère est une sorcière maman ma
petite mère
tu crois que c'est toi qui décides quand
tu t'en vas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]